lassen sie uns nicht sterben fleht diese
ukrainerin den tokio demonstrierten um
ihre angehörigen in kiew band wie wir
zeigen menschen rund um den globus ihr
mitgefühl ihre solidarität
im land ruft präsident seelands die
seine landsleute dazu auf ihre heimat zu
verteidigen und nicht russischen
falschinformationen aufzusetzen auch er
präsident hat weiter mcf aus
ein dramatischer appell des ukrainischen
präsidenten selensky zum durchhalten
herzlich willkommen zu einem weiteren
zdf spezial
gestern hatte wladimir selensky davor
gewarnt es könnte eine entscheidende
nacht sein doch trotz heftiger angriffe
ist die hauptstadt kiew noch nicht unter
russische kontrolle
die truppen aber rücken immer weiter vor
russland kündigte am frühen abend dann
seine offensive auszuweiten über 100.000
ukrainer frauen kinder sind bereits in
die nachbarländer geflohen
darüber berichten wir heute abend
natürlich auch doch zunächst cornelia
donath mit einem überblick über die lage
am tag drei des angriffs russlands auf
die ukraine es ist acht uhr 12 zeit kiew
als die rakete in das hochhaus
einschlägt ein loch klafft zwischen dem
18 und 21 stock retter tragen verletzte
aus dem gebäude in der lobau noski
straße 6a im südwesten der hauptstadt
ganz in der nähe des flughafens sikorski
wir suchen weiter nach verletzten bis
jetzt haben wir sechs gefunden zwei
stockwerke standen in flammen 80
menschen könnten wir evakuieren
in der nacht durchdringen immer wieder
schüsse und explosionen die dunkelheit
sogar rund 800 meter vom
regierungsviertel entfernt waren
detonationen zu hören
am morgen zeigen sich auch hier nach
einer bahnstation die trümmer der
vergangenen nacht den menschen steckt
der schock in den knochen ein großes
glück für sie die gleise wurden nicht
zerstört
es ist schrecklicher terrorismus das
denken wir alten ich werde 84 wir sind
alle besorgt um die anbindung hier denn
die ist unser leben so kommen wir auf
den markt
nach kämpfen im norden der stadt meldet
das ukrainische energieministerium die
eigenen truppen halten die kontrolle
über das dortige wasserkraftwerk unklar
hingegen soll die lage auf dem flughafen
horst uhl seien sieben kilometer von
kiew entfernt zwar zeigen fotos einen
abgeschossenen russischen hubschrauber
aber das russische militär hat nach
eigenen angaben den flughafen
eingenommen so könnte es soldaten direkt
an den stadtrand von tier fliegen
außerdem sollen dort truppen ein treffen
die von belarus aus über tschernobyl auf
die hauptstadt vorstoßen das kraftwerk
liegt für die russen strategisch wichtig
direkt an der straße nach kiew nur 120
kilometer entfernt
invasiv südlich von kiew wollten laut
der bürgermeisterin russische
fallschirmjäger einen militärstützpunkt
einnehmen nach heftigen kämpfen und
schweren verlusten habe der angriff
jedoch abgewehrt werden können bestätigt
ist das nicht
milito poll im südosten hingegen soll
das russische militär erobert haben und
damit eine erste größere ukrainische
stadt auch hier fehlt die bestätigung
die angriffe gehen auch im osten des
landes weiter in kharkiv der
zweitgrößten stadt sowie in lohans
grundton jetzt bei den kämpfen der
letzten nacht ist hier die
wasserversorgung zerstört worden jetzt
stehen die menschen an um ihre flaschen
zu füllen tag drei im krieg der für sich
hier in den besetzten gebieten schon so
viel länger dauert die kleinen betten
und der spielplatz lassen vermuten auch
ein kinderheim wurde getroffen
und über die militärische lage in der
ukraine wollen wir auch heute wieder mit
den ehemaligen nato general egon ramms
sprechen genannt wo bibel noch ist also
nicht gefallen aber ist das nur noch
eine frage der zeit
nein das würde ich so nicht gewollt sein
sondern ich glaube dass die pläne die us
bank gab das tier zu nehmen und durch
den einsatz der ukrainische schreibe
schon ein bisschen verlangsamt es bleibt
abzuwarten wie sich die lage weiter
entwickelt kiew geht jetzt bot die
nächste nacht hinein wenn ich einige
berichte heute richtig verstanden habe
geht man davon aus dass sich seine töre
oder sabotage truppen möglicherweise in
kiew befinden aber bisher noch keine
geschlossene informationen der
russischen landstreitkräfte
ein hauptziel russlands ist das wohl die
regierung sei jens g abzusetzen er ist
aber nicht wie von den usa angeboten
geflohen sondern hart weiter aus wie
wichtig ist das
also ich denke dass das für die moral
der ukrainischen bevölkerung der
zivilbevölkerung aber auch für die moral
der iranischen truppen ein ganz
wichtiger punkt ist und ich finde die
tatsache dass präsident selensky gestern
abend wollte morgen auch noch mal wieder
botschaften über die sozialen medien hat
seine bevölkerung und sonders soldaten
schickt ausgesprochen gutes zusammen mit
können sagt es mal mit meinen worten
russland nicht konkurrieren worden
man bekommt ja nicht viele überprüfbare
informationen dass sollen aber wieder
russische soldaten ums leben gekommen
seien oder verhaftet was wären sie da
also muss ich an der stelle wirklich
passen weil ich darüber keine kenntnisse
aber es gibt hinweise für mich
formuliere es mal vorsichtig wobei ich
kann bodycount ding machen möchte dass
offensichtlich die verluste der
russischen streitkräfte höher sind aus
die verluste der ukrainische staat wie
lustig gewisse
deutschland hat ja immer eine
waffenlieferung abgelehnt heute abend
wurde nun doch die lieferung genehmigt
da geht es um panzerabwehrwaffen sowie
500 boden luft raketen vom typ sting aus
bundeswehrbeständen wie wichtig ist
seine unterstützung
weiß ich glaube dass dieses erst mal ein
ganz wichtiges signal ist bei dem konzer
abwehrwaffen handelt es sich vermutlich
oder wahrscheinlich um die sogenannte
panzerfaust 3
hier haben die niederländer
möglicherweise ein tor geöffnet nehmen
sie zuerst gesagt haben dass sie 400
bereitstellen wollen und für die ukraine
und danach ist deutschland hinterher
gegangen mit der zahl 1000 ob das jetzt
insgesamt 1400 oder die schüler
niederländischen in den pausen beziehung
ist eine frage die kann ich im
augenblick noch nicht beantworten weil
diese meldung jetzt im augenblick gerade
ich sage einmal 40 minuten alt sind und
so schnell so schnell geht das nicht die
stinger schulter gestützte
flugabwehrraketen wäre ein ganz
wichtiger punkt weil wir bisher davon
ausgehen dass die russische luftwaffe
die luftüberlegenheit in über der
ukraine
und da ist diese schulter gestützte
waffe drückt ein mittel um diese
luftüberlegenheit zumindest sagen ich
mal weiter einzuschränken oder
einzuschränken sie wird nicht zum
vollständigen abschluss alle russischen
luftfahrzeuge führen aber zumindest muss
das verhalten der piloten sich dann
deutlich ändern und es ist dann schon
ein hohes risiko für sie ja die ukraine
fordert ja die ganze zeit schon weiter
vehement defensivwaffen vom besten
welche sind dann von besonderer
bedeutung sie haben es gerade schon
welche angesprochen aber gerade von zu
diesem zeitungen zeitpunkt also wir sind
ja bei dem thema defensivwaffen im
augenblick wir haben auch in deutschland
weil wir keine haben keine möglichkeiten
kampfpanzer zu liefern würden dieses
vermutlich auch nicht aus politischen
gründen machen aber das beispiel
flugabwehr schulter geschützte
flugabwehrwaffen ist schon ein wichtiges
beispiel und da die russische seite ja
mit panzern und schützenpanzern verrückt
ist auch die panzerfaust allerdings nur
für den bereich im näheren umfeld ist
wie würde geschützt weil er durchaus
geeignete waffe um panzer zu bekämpfen
vielen dank an hans
herzlichen dank
das ist ein klarer angriff ein krieg
gegen einen souveränen staat in russland
da führt davon darf aber in russischen
medien nicht gesprochen werden da sollen
es offiziell nur friedenstruppen seien
eine dreiste lüge und nicht die einzige
über die ids informationskampagne
moskaus martin cordes
es war eine freie geheime allgemeine
wahl am 21 april 2009 10 bei der
wolodimir seelands die mit 73 prozent
der stimmen zum präsidenten der ukraine
gewählt wurde russlands präsident putin
dagegen spricht von einer
volksfeindlichen runter die mithilfe
eines fingierten
wahlverfahrens die ukraine als geisel
genommen habe mit solchen
falschinformationen
deutet der kreml-chef die wahrheit um im
osten der ukraine seien es nicht
pro-russische separatisten die seit
jahren krieg führen sondern die ukraine
vor über dort einen genozid an millionen
von menschen solche behauptungen stützt
die russische seite auch auf bilder die
gefälscht und offensichtlich inszeniert
sind
hier sollen gnaden jetzt ukrainische
saboteure ein ziviles auto angegriffen
haben bei dem angriff seien mehrere
zivilisten zu tode gekommen berichtet
ein reporter im fahrzeug sind
anscheinend die fast vollständig
verbrannten überreste mehrerer menschen
zu sehen ein leichnam allerdings weist
am schädel die glatten schnitte einer
knochensäge auf das typische bild nach
einer autopsie am verbrannten fahrzeug
fehlen die nummernschilder die alles
deutet auf eine inszenierung hin wurden
hier bereits verstorbene menschen als
opfer eines klinischen anschlags
präsentiert
eindeutig manipuliert ist dieses video
angeblich stirbt hier ein saboteur im
auftrag der ukraine der sich angeblich
selbst mit einer helmkamera bei seinem
sabotage angriff fehlt im hintergrund
spielt geräusche eines schweren gefechts
vermutlich hat dieses gefecht nie
stattgefunden denn experten haben in den
metadaten des videos nachgewiesen dass
die tonspur gefälscht ist der ton ist
kopiert worden von diesem youtube video
das seine finnische armee übung zeigt
die tonspuren beide videos sind absolut
identisch
auch dieser angebliche angriff der
ukraine auf stellungen der separatisten
ist nicht das was die russische seite
behauptet wieder soll ein ukrainer mit
der eigenen helm kamera gefilmt haben
bevor er angeblich getötet wurde das
kann nicht stimmen journalisten konnten
den ort der videoaufnahmen zweifelsfrei
bestimmen weit entfernt von den
behaupteten kampfhandlungen in den
russischen medien aber auch in sozialen
netzwerken weltweit verbreiten solche
bilder die russische version des
konflikts
und so ist russlands krieg den putins
sprache kein krieg keine invasion
sondern eine spezialoperation um
russland unser volk zu verteidigen
und darüber reden möchte ich mit dem
leiter der task force für
falschinformationen der eu-hilfsgelder
genannt
guten abend herr güllner welche sind
denn für sie die gravierendsten
falschinformationen die sie gerade
beobachten
ja wir beobachten ja schon seit jahren
die
medien und so genannten medien die vom
kreml kontrolliert werden oder mit ihm
zusammen hängen manchmal sogar tief in
mit dem geheimdienst auch verbunden sind
und da gibt es immer wieder einige
erzählungen die da ganz besonders hervor
gestellt werden momentan geht es
natürlich um den krieg an sich es geht
um praktisch um kriegspropaganda es wird
praktisch nur die eine seite dargestellt
gewinne der russischen seite verluste
werden nur auf der ukrainischen seite
dargestellt ganz klare propaganda wie
man sie vielleicht auch schon früher
gesehen hat was neu ist allerdings ist
dieser ganz klarer fokus auf die ukraine
diesem land das existenzrecht
abzusprechen es zu verunglimpfen als
nazi zersetzt oder selbst gar nicht als
land das ist ein narrativ der neues und
sehr starkes ja wir haben es gesagt
putin spricht ja von einer notwendigen
entnazifizierung der ukraine dabei ist
der ukrainische präsident seelands
gesetz aus einer jüdischen familie
warum wird putins lügen trotz solcher
eindeutigen fakten geglaubt
ja ich weiß nicht wer ihm glaubt aber
wichtig ist natürlich dass es passiert
und das ist auch nicht seit gestern erst
sondern eigentlich schon seit jahren
spätestens seit der annexion der krim
haben wir gerade in diesen programmen
medien immer wieder diese erzählung
gesehen das sind nazis das land ist
korrupt das ist sowieso teil russlands
und das hat sich zum teil an die
bevölkerung der ukraine gerichtet
nämlich da das vertrauen zu zerstören
die stabilität auch zu unterminieren
sollte aber auch eine ganz klar
nachricht in den westen sein dass dieses
land eigentlich gar keine unterstützung
verdient in russland wurde es verboten
dass in berichten über den krieg gegen
die ukraine worte wie angriff invasion
oder krieg benutzt werden kann so ein
verbieten von worten wirklich die macht
der bilder von tod zerstörung flucht
abschwächen
ja natürlich nicht wenn es echte bilder
sind was uns große sorgen macht sind
natürlich diese manipulationen die
konstruierten bilder und wir haben das
auch schon seit jahren gesehen gerade in
den letzten wochen in der vorbereitung
bevor der angriff dann tatsächlich
losging wurden immer wieder situationen
kreiert mit sogenannten oder angeblichen
bombenanschlägen und ähnlichem da wird
dann bildmaterial
manipuliert auch inhaltlich einfach
immer wieder falsch dargestellt das
heißt da muss man wirklich sehr genau
aufpassen wie kann denn jeder einzelne
erkennen was man falsch oder richtig ist
ja da gibt es natürlich nicht ganz
einfach ein ganz einfaches mittel aber
was das allerwichtigste ist ist ein
gesundes misstrauen mitzubringen bei
bildmaterial oder textmaterial von dem
man gar nicht weiß woher das kommt
gerade die so genannten programme medien
viele auch staatlich kontrolliert machen
das ja schon seit wochen seit monaten
vielleicht sogar seit jahren benutzten
diese manipulation und ich glaube
wirklich äußerste vorsicht dem zu
glauben ist angebracht vielen dank lutz
göllner
danke ja das gespräch haben wir heute
nachmittag aus termingründen wo
aufgezeichnet live in moskau ist für uns
jetzt unser korrespondent christian sen
was bekommt denn die russische
bevölkerung vor dem krieg in der ukraine
mit welche falschinformationen sind
besonders auffällig
ich würde sagen es ist sehr
unterschiedlich das staatsfernsehen er
ums leben ich gehört es ist immer noch
ein sehr wichtiges medium wird vor allem
von älteren menschen hier konsumiert und
wenn wir unsere straßenumfragen machen
und mit den menschen sprechen wie sie
den konflikt im moment sehen dann hören
wir oft die argumente die auch im
staatsfernsehen fallen dass die ukraine
ein der angefallener staates ein
zerstörter start ist der falsch geführt
ist von neonazis geführt wird und dass
der konflikt im prinzip unausweichlich
war weil das land ebenso schlecht
geführt wird und russland da jetzt rein
gehen musste in form von einer
friedensmission von einer militärischen
option und nicht von einem angriffskrieg
das wird hier so nicht gesehen von
diesen älteren menschen dann gibt es
andere gruppen die informieren sich über
die wenigen freien medien die es noch
gibt über die wenigen zeitungen und
onlinemedien wo eine differenzierte
berichterstattung stattfindet da können
sich die menschen auch informieren und
natürlich die verschiedenen social media
kanäle aber es ist natürlich arbeit sich
diese informationen zu besorgen ja wie
groß ist denn die unterstützung für den
krieg im moment wie groß der protest ich
glaube ich sehe polizei hinter ihm
ja das richtig wir sind hier am
puschkinplatz im herzen moskaus und er
hat es wieder eine kundgebung gegeben
heute abend hunderte menschen waren hier
schwer zu schätzen wie viele es genau
waren die haben sich hier in dem areal
verteilt und die waren einfach nur hier
und haben einen stillen protest gemacht
und wollten zeigen dass sie mit diesem
krieg mit dieser aktion mit diesen
handlungen nicht einverstanden sind die
polizei wiederum die sicherheitskräfte
die ist nicht damit einverstanden dass
die menschen einfach demonstrieren das
ist in russland faktisch unmöglich
geworden und wir haben auch einige
festnahmen gesehen also die menschen
versuchen das im kleinen zu
versuchen zu protestieren aber ich
glaube es gibt auch eine große gruppe
die ist frustriert weil sie weiß dass
dieser protest wenig chancen hat gehört
zu werden und sie haben natürlich auch
angst dass wenn sie auf die straße gehen
dass sie dann festgenommen werden sowie
wird das heute abend auch wieder erlebt
haben vielen dank christian senn
von den sanktionen des westens hat sich
putin bisher nicht abschrecken lassen er
droht seinerseits mit vergeltung was
kommt da auch auf deutschland zu auch im
flora über die wirtschaftlichen folgen
des krieges
es wird geschweißt und geschraubt bei
zeppelin in böblingen früher mal
luftschiffbauer heute verkaufen sie
amerikanische baumaschinen der marke
caterpillar weltweit die ukraine ein
wichtiger markt mit einem standort und
600 ortsansässigen mitarbeitern seit
drei tagen arbeiten die firmenleitung
allerdings vor allem für deren
sicherheit
kann ihnen sagen wir haben busse in die
kriegs regionen geschickt um unsere
mitarbeiter dort herauszuholen einige
haben das in anspruch genommen viele
sind auch einfach geblieben weil sie
gesagt haben wir müssen uns mit der
zukünftigen
situation auseinandersetzen wir wollen
unsere heimat nicht verlassen
erst mal geht es um die menschen dann
aber auch ums geschäft da stehen für
zeppelin 800 millionen euro jahresumsatz
auf dem spiel 20 prozent des
gesamtgeschäfts und das wird wohl nicht
mehr wie es bis vor drei tagen einmal
war
wir werden in den nächsten jahren
sicherlich die märkte ukraine und
russland anders betrachten müssen und in
unseren ausrichtungen dort auch anders
verfolgen müssen das heißt also das
heutige geschäft wie wir es kennen in
osteuropa in der ukraine und in russland
wird zukünftig für uns in der form nicht
mehr stattfinden damit wird zeppelin
nicht alleine stehen knapp 2.000
deutsche unternehmen sind derzeit in der
ukraine aktiv über 3600 in russland
große player dort sind beispielsweise
der metro handelskonzern er betreibt 93
märkte mit etwa 10.000 mitarbeitern oder
der chemieriese basf hat zwölf werke mit
700 mitarbeitern
mercedes hat ein werk in der nähe von
moskau mit 1000 beschäftigten
der hamburger hafen tor zur welt
sinnbild und hotspot der exportnation
einer der wichtigsten europäischen
anlaufpunkte von hier ist sankt
petersburg noch
2020 exportierte deutschland güter im
wert von 26 milliarden euro nach
russland 2 prozent des gesamt export
wichtige güter waren maschinen autos
elektrotechnik und chemie
umgekehrt liefert russland vor allem
rohstoffe natürlich öl und gas aber auch
ärzte und getreide
energie und mehl für die back straßen
bei süßwaren gigant lamberts in aachen
wird beides dringend benötigt lebkuchen
und printen machen sie hier die liebe zu
beiden teilen russen und ukrainer nicht
nur an weihnachten ein schöner
wachstumsmarkt dachte hermann bühlbecker
chef der lambertz-gruppe er investierte
vor vielen jahren jetzt scheint alles in
gefahr der absatz die guten beziehungen
die man viele jahre pflegte und er ist
sich sicher versorgungsschwierigkeiten
werden kommen für lambertz und viele
andere unternehmen steigende gas öl
strompreise aluminium er wird uns alle
treffen wird auch dieses unternehmen
wieder in seiner kostenstruktur treffen
und wir sind vielleicht auch besonders
noch betroffen insofern als russland
weizen
lieferant der weltnummer 1 ist ukraine
ist weizen an bauland in der weltnummer
2 und sind natürlich auch sofort gleich
die weizenpreise dramatisch hoch
gegangen
energiepreise werden weiter steigen
produzieren wir teurer produkte damit
auch putins krieg wird so auch
deutschlands wirtschaftliches leben
nachhaltig beeinflussen
ja darüber reden wir jetzt mit stefan
kooths vom kieler institut für
weltwirtschaft guten abend guten abend
bisher hat sich deutschland immer
geweigert russmann auswirft
auszuschließen jetzt soll es wohl doch
eine gezielte aussetzung von swift geben
was kann das bedeuten
mit swift geht es ja darum die
finanzströme aus und nach russland zu
kappen um damit das land umfassend
außenwirtschaftlich zu isolieren und
werden jetzt gesagt wird gezielte
sanktionen
nun dann ist es eben weniger umfassend
dann werden hier ausnahmen gemacht und
die frage die im raum steht ist
natürlich betrifft das auch die
energieimporte aus russland dass es die
eigentliche frage um die es dabei geht
bisher hat sich putin von sanktionen
nicht abschrecken lassen treffen sehen
gar nicht wir sind da ihre berechnungen
russland wird langfristig hier deutlich
unter diesen sanktionen leiden auch von
der isolation aus der übrigen welt
ausgeschlossen zu sein das wird
langfristig sehr teuer für russland
russland ist ohnehin wirtschaftlich
schwach aufgestellt nur das sind eben
alles effekte die zeit brauchen bis sie
wirken und kurzfristig können sie ebenso
eine kriegerische aggression nicht
lahmlegen vermutlich wird putin auch
diese reaktion des westens schon
vorweggenommen haben also kurzfristig
kann man ihm damit nicht in den arm
fallen aber langfristig verschiebt sich
das ökonomische kräfteverhältnis
zwischen dem westen und russland immer
mehr und wenn wir einfach mal eine zahl
betrachten die wirtschaftsleistung der
westlichen länder beträgt das elffache
dessen was wir in russland haben und das
wird sich im zweifel sogar noch zu
lasten von russland weiter auseinander
entwickeln und das kann man auf dauer
dann eben nicht durchhalten wie schwer
treffen wir sanktionen die deutsche
wirtschaft das ist jetzt genau die frage
wo wir unterscheiden müssen zwischen
unseren energieimporten und im übrigen
handelt sie haben die zahlen ja gerade
gezeigt russland steht für nicht mal
zwei prozent unseres außenhandels das
ist nicht viel die deutsche industrie
geht mit einem vielfachen an auftrags
überhängen in dieses jahr hinein als wir
überhaupt waren exporte nach russland
haben für einzelne unternehmen kann das
hart sein diejenigen die im russland
geschäft stark exponiert sind dass es
gar keine frage aber
gesamtwirtschaftlich ist das nichts was
bei uns eine krise auslösen würde zumal
ja auch die industrie derzeit
absatzmöglichkeiten hat die sie gar
nicht bedienen kann die güter die jetzt
nicht nach russland geliefert werden
können werden dann auch woanders in der
welt relativ leicht absatz finden die
andere frage ist eben wie schnell können
wir auf energielieferungen aus russland
verzichten falls sie denn unterbrochen
werden sollten von welcher seite auch
immer und da stellt sich vor allen
dingen beim gas natürlich die frage
was wir da wie schnell tun können und da
ist das schon kurzfristig problematisch
insbesondere wenn es dann darum gehen
müsste einzelne industrieunternehmen
abzuschalten das würde dann unmittelbar
die wirtschaftsleistung hierzulande wohl
auch spürbarer treffen vielen dank
stefan kooths
am ende ist es nur geld es geht aber
hier um die nationale sicherheit
das sagte wirtschaftsminister habe ich
will die menschen in der ukraine ist der
krieg eine tragödie da geht es um die
demokratie ums nackte überleben
die ereignisse des tages zusammengefasst
von gert anhalt
ein kalter strahlender morgen in kiew
nach einer langen und bangen nacht für
die der fall der hauptstadt nicht
ausgeschlossen wurde aber die
verteidigungslinien scheinen gehalten zu
haben
und zwar schon klar dass diese nacht
schwierig werden würde denn die russen
wollten uns größtmöglichen schaden
zufügen
aber das ist ihnen nicht gelungen
gefechtslärm drang aus den vororten es
gab angriffe vor allem auf
militäranlagen und flughäfen sowie ein
kraftwerk am morgen präsentierten die
verteidiger dann die überreste eines
mutmaßlichen russischen konvois der vor
der hauptstadt gestoppt worden sei
insgesamt so das militär wurden bisher
über 500 russische fahrzeuge zerstört
sowie 102 panzer und 14 flugzeuge
bürgermeister klitschko meldete sich mit
einer beruhigenden botschaft freunde und
bürger von gf diese nacht war hart aber
es sind keine russischen truppen in die
stadt vorgedrungen sie versuchen es
weiter vor allem von westen her aber wir
haben sie zurückgeschlagen
35 einwohner seien in der nacht
verwundet worden darunter zwei kinder
und weithin sichtbar zeugte ein von
einer rakete getroffen das wohnhaus in
der nähe des flughafens von den
gefechten um die 2,8 millionen stadt ein
angriff den es nach aussagen der
russischen seite gar nicht gegeben haben
kann
lassen sie mich noch einmal betonen dass
unsere angriffe nur auf einrichtungen
der armee zielen und das schließt
schäden an wohngebäuden und ziviler
infrastruktur aus
zusicherungen auf die sich die käfer
bevölkerung oft aus eigener erfahrung
nicht mehr verlassen möchte
weiter versuchen tausende die hauptstadt
zu verlassen die u bahn stationen sind
anlaufstellen für alle die die
ungewissheit nicht mehr ertragen
das schlimmste ist man weiß ja nicht wie
das alles hier aus geht und wann
mitfahrgelegenheiten und private taxi
angebote stehen hier für die bereit die
sich das leisten können
aber die fahrt hinaus aus der stadt ist
auch nichts für schwache nerven wie ein
britisches fernsehteam feststellt
bewaffnete milizionäre hätten sie an um
sie zu kontrollieren und überall ist
militär
eine familie auf der flucht wir können
nicht mehr nach hause sagt die frau mit
dem baby auf dem arm als der reporter
die oma nach ihrer meinung zu tun fragt
geschützfeuer
dass da das ist putin sagt sie und
weiter geht die reise
und weiter warten aber tausende auf den
bahnhöfen wie hier in lwiw dem alten
lemberg auf den zug in die sicherheit es
ist die größte in europäische
flüchtlingswelle seit dem balkankrieg
immer wieder wird über die sozialen
medien verbreitet auch der staatschef
habe das land verlassen
dem trat präsident zielinski am morgen
mit einer video botschaft entgegen mit
dem handy aufgenommen vor dem haus der
chinesen einem bekannten wahrzeichen
gleich gegenüber von seinem amtssitz in
kiew im netz gibt es viele fake news
sagte aber ich bin hier wir geben nicht
auf wir werden unser land verteidigen
das russische fernsehen zeigt
unterdessen wie ein panzer chor ohne
hoheitszeichen in eine nicht näher
beschriebene schlacht zieht es sind
russische separatisten in der region du
kannst wann und wo genau die bilder
aufgenommen wurden wird nicht erwähnt
viel wichtiger als das sind ohnehin die
prorussischen patriotischen botschaften
wir verteidigen unsere heimat unsere
kinder unsere häuser darauf haben wir
seit acht jahren gewartet
während aus den weiter westlich
gelegenen landesteilen und vor allem aus
kiew noch keine großen erfolgsmeldungen
kommen konzentriert sich russlands
propaganda auf die sogenannten
volksrepublik
zum ersten mal seit acht jahren greifen
wir nun an von hier gehen wir keinen
schritt zurück nur vorwärts die schäden
an den wohnhäusern in bonn jetzt gehen
auf das konto der ukraine klagt
russlands staatsfernsehen an und lässt
zahlreiche dankbare einwohner zu wort
kommen auffällig dass jeder ausdrücklich
die vergangenen acht jahre erwähnt und
das jahr 2014 fast als hätten sie sich
abgesprochen
wir wurden hier acht jahre lang
unterdrückt und haben nichts gesagt
obwohl das sonst gar nicht unsere art
ist
2014 das war ein schock aber jetzt
drücken unsere soldaten vor hurra
russland
und die selbsternannten volksvertreter
dürfen ihre vision von demnächst
blühenden landschaften ausbreiten als
erstes müssen wir die produktion
ankurbeln um den lebensstandard
anzuheben es wird steuererleichterungen
geben und auch kredite zu günstigen
bedingungen
steuererlass und aufbauhilfe im osten
der ukraine reden sie als sei dieser
krieg schon vorbei
und in der ukraine ist für uns katrin
eigendorf rund 200 kilometer südwestlich
von kiew
nach wie vor ist die lage auch hier in
wien zu 200 kilometer von kiew entfernt
sehr angespannt man geht davon aus dass
russland hier doch zu wesentlich
drastischeren maßnahmen in diesem krieg
greifen wird aber dennoch fokussiert
sich natürlich die beobachtung vor allem
auf kiew denn es geht ja darum dass
wladimir putin angekündigt hat und das
auch sein erklärtes ziel ist erst einmal
jetzt die hauptstadt erobern die
regierung zu entmachten und dort ein
marionettenregime zu installieren auch
die ukraine richten ihren fokus auf kiew
der bürgermeister von kiew vitali
klitschko aber auch der ukrainische
präsident selent ski versuchen die
bevölkerung darauf einzuschwören dass
sie sich jetzt hier auf einen längeren
belagerungszustand einrichten müssen sie
appellieren daran selbst zu den waffen
zu greifen im prinzip die militärs zu
unterstützen leute werden aufgefordert
selbst molotow cocktails zu bauen sich
es wurden breitflächig waffen ausgegeben
man richtet sich darauf ein dass
russland mit bodentruppen versuchen wird
in die stadt zu kontrollieren
und da baut man eben wie gesagt nicht
nur alleine auf die armee sondern vor
allem auch auf die bevölkerung die moral
soll hier hochgehalten werden deswegen
richtet sich der präsident im prinzip
den ganzen tag immer wieder mit neuen
video botschaften an die bevölkerung und
auch seine frau hat sich mittlerweile
hier eingeschaltet und wirbt dafür und
sagt die armee das sind wir wir das volk
vielen dank katrin eigendorf und passen
sich gut ob sich auf
polen slowakei ungarn moldau und
rumänien die nachbarstaaten sind das
ziel der vor dem krieg fliehen den
ukrainerinnen und ukrainer
laut vereinten nationen haben seit
beginn der inversion bisher über 110.000
menschen ihre heimat verlassen zu dem
irren tausende als binnenflüchtlinge
durch die ukraine werde es gerade
gesehen über die situation an den
grenzen isabel termine
die menschen kommen mit dem was sie
tragen können frauen und kinder die ihre
männer und väter zurücklassen mussten
die dürfen nicht über die grenze sollen
kämpfen für ihr land
seit kriegsbeginn sollen in polen rund
hunderttausend flüchtlinge aus dem
nachbarland angekommen sein viele haben
hier freunde und verwandte flucht aus
dem krieg
es ist so schrecklich schrecklich mein
herz bricht alle weine
explosionen
einfach nur schrecklich
vor der grenze stundenlanges warten
zdf-reporter lothar becker war auf der
anderen seite in der ukraine unterwegs
und berichtet von der flucht über 25
kilometer zieht sich der stau bis wir
den grenzposten medica auf ukrainischer
seite erreichen davor tausende
flüchtende meist frauen und kinder zu
fuß ohne panik warten sie überstunden
oder die ganze nacht weil die
ukrainischen grenze nur stoßweise kleine
gruppen durch lassen überall meinen
kinder die temperaturen längst unter dem
gefrierpunkt verpflegung sanitäre
einrichtungen medizinische versorgung
gibt es nicht nur die kälte eine
humanitäre katastrophe
auch im slowakischen vize kommen
kriegsflüchtlinge an frauen und kinder
ältere männer hinter dem schlagbaum
europa sicherheit frieden
wolodimir iwanow hat es geschafft
erzählt von der ersten kriegs nacht in
charkiw
das haus fing an zu beben
richtig zu wackeln ich habe es erst
nicht verstanden ich dachte in der nähe
ist ein jugendclub da wird gefeiert und
da würde jemand früher werk machen
es sind vor allem freiwillige die hier
helfen patrick hat einen kleinen tisch
aufgebaut versucht flüchtlinge und
freiwillige zusammen zu bringen
viele hier kommen um zu helfen
sie bieten unterkünfte 30 60 oder sogar
200 betten
ich kam gestern nach der arbeit hierher
um zu helfen und jetzt organisiere ich
das alles die unterkunft und den
transport
anastasia war zehn stunden unterwegs 450
kilometer liegen hinter ihr
[Musik]
meine mutter und mein vater sind in der
armee sie sind zu hause geblieben
und sie können nicht weg und sie haben
freunde gefragt mich hierher zu bringen
es war hart alles zurückzulassen mein
hund meine eltern
und so stellen sie sich hier ein auf
viele tausend menschen die in den
nächsten tagen den weg in die freiheit
suchen
und in berlin ist jetzt christoph jung
leiter für internationale zusammenarbeit
beim deutschen roten kreuz welche
informationen bekommen sie denn aus kiel
von ihren mitarbeitern vor ort die
mitarbeitenden in kiew sind mehr oder
minder rund um die uhr tätig sie
arbeiten sehr oft im keller das heißt
die situation ist sehr angespannt es
gibt immer wieder warnungen vor
angriffen und man versucht von kiew aus
die arbeit im ganzen land zu
organisieren wo tausende von
freiwilligen des ukrainischen roten
kreuzes seit dem beginn des konfliktes
nun ihre arbeit tun und bereits mehr als
30.000 menschen helfen konnten und wir
unterstützen sie denn die menschen die
jetzt an den grenzen zu polen und
slowakei zu tausenden versuchen die
ukraine zu verlassen wir beobachten die
situation sehr eng und es war ein
beitrag gerade gezeigt die
warteschlangen sind sehr lang teilweise
wird berichtet von mehr als 70 stunden
wartezeit wir machen gerade gemeinsam
mit dem polnischen roten kreuz errichten
wir lagerhäuser oder staaten lagerhäuser
im südosten polens aus mit ganz
einfachen hilfsgütern das sind
feldbetten das sind decken
hygieneartikel all diese dinge um dann
die ankommenden menschen mit dem
notdürftig ssten zu unterstützen ja was
brauchen die menschen am dringendsten
sie sprechen von notbetten aber was was
ist noch was sie brauchen wenn sie es
denn in die nachbarländer geschafft
haben ja es sind natürlich zum einen
diese dinge die ich gerade schilderte
zum anderen werden wir den menschen aber
auch dinge wie power banks also die
möglichkeit geben ihre telefone auf zu
lernen damit sie kontakt zu ihren
familien zu freunden verwandten
aufnehmen können und die menschen sind
natürlich traumatisiert wir werden
versuchen sehr niederschwellig eine
psychosoziale betreuung sicherzustellen
um die menschen einfach in diesem
schrecklichen ereignissen zu begleiten
und wie bereitet man sich in deutschland
auf ankommende flüchtlinge vor mit wie
vielen rechnern
ich glaube dazu können wir jedenfalls
derzeit keine seriösen aus treffen aber
selbstverständlich macht das rote kreuz
sowohl hier auf berliner ebene als auch
auf länder- und kommunaler ebene spricht
mit den behörden spricht mit anderen
organisationen so dass wir vorbereitet
sein werden wenn menschen hierher kommen
vielen dank christoph ionen danke ihnen
wenn sie den menschen in der ukraine
helfen wollen können sie das tun beim
aktionsbündnis katastrophenhilfe
stichwort zdf nothilfe ukraine bahn.de
65 104 106 100 104 106 100 alle infos
auch unter spenden zdf de oder im zdf
text auf seite 8 190
helfen wolle viel die solidarität haben
wir gesehen ist groß und weltweit gibt
es auch proteste gegen die invasion
russlands
[Musik]
gegen den krieg in brasilien singen sie
die ukrainische nationalhymne
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ob in australien spanien oder taiwan der
feldzug des russischen präsidenten
treibt die menschen auf die straße wie
auch hier in kalifornien und sogar
russland
besonders ist eine großkundgebung in
berlin geplant
und dann rede ich zum schluss noch mit
russland expertin sarah packung guten
abend herr
packung noch hat putin kiew nicht
erobert hätte er sich das einfacher
vorgestellt
die gebietsgewinne die russische armee
bis jetzt gemacht hat sind sicher nicht
so groß wie man das in moskau erwartet
hat ich glaube das hängt zum einen auch
mit einer etwas falschen einschätzung
der lage zusammen auch mit verhalten
geheimdienstlichen erkenntnissen zum
anderen hat man mal ganz offensichtlich
auch die widerstandsfähigkeit auch die
gegenwehr der ukrainer und ukrainerinnen
unterschätzt es gab ja zwischendurch
auch angebliche verhandlungsangebote
russlands wie schätzen sie die 1
ich gehe nicht davon aus dass es
wirklich glaubwürdig war also zum einen
weil wir ja in den letzten tagen und
wochen immer wieder gesehen haben dass
russlands verhandlungsbereitschaft nur
vorgeschützt war und zum anderen sind
die bedingungen die man dafür gestellt
hat ja so weit gehend gewesen dass es im
grunde genommen eine absolute
kapitulation der ukraine gewesen wäre
also man hätte nur wenn überhaupt zu
verhandlungen kommen können wenn man die
ukraine so wie wir sie heute kennen
natürlich komplett aufgegeben hätte ja
es gibt weltweit proteste gegen den
krieg auch in russland könnte das für
den präsidenten ernsthaft zu einer
gefahr werden
also der repressionsapparat in russland
scheint momentan noch relativ gut zu
funktionieren er wird sogar ausgebaut
auch durch zu den suhr allerdings nimmt
auch sagen dass die kosten die man in
moskau auf sich nimmt durch den krieg an
sich durch die invasion durch auch dann
ein besatzungsregime durch die
sanktionen enorm sind und es ist gerade
eigentlich nicht möglich abzuschätzen ob
das dazu führt dass das regime näher
zusammenrückt das repressiver wird oder
dass es vielleicht auch mittel bis
langfristig dann wirklich zu wissen
kommt was könnte putin überhaupt noch
stoppen und wo wird er mit seiner
aggression halt machen
also ich glaube das ist wirklich sehr
schwer zu sagen und ich traue mich
ehrlich gesagt momentan auch nicht mehr
vorher zu sagen ob es wirklich die
ukraine ist oder ob nicht auch andere
länder wie beispielsweise melonen risiko
ausgesetzt sind ich glaube das was man
machen kann es eben die kosten für
moskau wirkliche soweit zu erhöhen wie
jetzt irgendwie geht auch um deutlich zu
machen dass es hier eine grenze gibt
dass das langfristige folgen haben wird
und zwar auch folgen innerhalb russlands
sprechen sie schon an was kann sollte
der westen noch tun also die kosten
hochtreiben
ja also ich glaube man hat wenn man eben
nicht militärisch einschreitet zwei
instrumente über das eine sind
waffenlieferungen
das muss jetzt wirklich schnell und gut
gehen es ist wichtig dass die deutsche
bundesregierung sich da jetzt bewegt
aber es kommt ehrlich gesagt auch ein
wenig spät und das andere sind
sanktionen und dann müssen wir auch über
das was wir bis jetzt haben hinausgehen
wirklich einen vollen stopp von swift
und darüber hinausgehend vor allen
dingen auch umfassende sanktionen gegen
die banken um den zahlungsverkehr nicht
nur zu verlangsamen sondern auch
wirklich aufzuhalten da muss ehrlich
gesagt was passieren auch wenn das
natürlich auswirkungen auf uns selber
haben wird und ihre prognose für die
nächsten tage
ich fürchte ehrlich gesagt dass trotz
der gegenwehr die ukraine nicht auf
dauer zu halten sein wird gegen russland
wir sehen gerade dass der russische
vorstoß verstoppt man aber mehr kräfte
zusammenzieht und das ist jetzt eben
möglicherweise auch brutaler gegen die
zivilbevölkerung in der ukraine sehen
wird also ich muss ganz ehrlich gestehen
ich habe kein gutes gefühl für die
nächsten tage
vielen dank zara packung
ja das war unser zdf spezial auch heute
nacht werden heftige kämpfe erwartet
main kiew gilt bis montagmorgen eine
ausgangssperre
wir berichten natürlich weiter heute
auch mit einem heute journal um 21 uhr
45 oder jederzeit unter zdf heute.de auf
wiedersehen
[Musik]
bleiben sie immer aktuell informiert im
zdf und der zdf-reihe
wind sind wenn doch ein ausnahme
künstler zwischen genie und wahnsinn
ein leben voller tragödien damen und
unglaublichen werten
lang verkannt ist er heute ein